[Music]
welcome to another stories from the
stores now we're joined today by curator
Sarah bond and she's told me that both
these objects been used to detect
pregnancy in the last hundred years
Sarah
how is this true both of them are used
to detect a hormone in pregnant woman's
urine called HCG the scientists first
discovered this hormone in the 20s HCG
is really important in in preserving the
pregnancy that's in the very early
stages before the placenta takes over
and when you introduce most animals to
this hormone they lock you late so the
same scientist that discovered HCG found
that if you injected it into an immature
female mice and rabbits they would start
to oscillate and their sexual organs
were good mature but they were expensive
and they took quite a long time just one
pregnancy test required five separate
mice and all of them had to be dissected
at the end of the process so by the
1930s scientists were wondering could
you use an animal that didn't need to be
dissected these are a species of
Japanese bitterling a tropical fish and
as you can probably see they've got
quite translucent skins so the fish have
an organ that they used to produce eggs
and that organ expands in the presence
of HCG and so you can see how this works
this first one here its organ it's
called an ovipositor is quite a bit
longer than the second one which is a
normal fish and the last one here is
just been dissected to show that organ a
little bit more clearly but essentially
that organ would go all the way from
about two millimeters up to about 25
millimeters was it super accurate no not
quite unfortunately that was the
sticking point with this test they
weren't very accurate and even men's
urine could often produce a positive
result so just a few years after the
fish a British urologist working in
South Africa found that if you injected
a particular type of frog with again
with president's woman's urine it would
spontaneously lay eggs what's more it
would do so within 12 hours so if the
animals are so good why did it take so
long to get to this well in fact the
frog test as it became known was used up
until the late sixties and early 1970s
and it absolutely was the standard
pregnancy test all over the world there
was a lot of drive to develop a test
that women could take in their own home
just like this one which is an early in
pregnancy test kit are still detecting
exactly the same hormone um it works
from a different process it's a chemical
process so no animals are involved so if
the frogs took like 12 hours how long
does this take
the very first became a core pregnancy
test took around 2 hours which was still
a vast improvement and now you can find
out the result in a matter of minutes so
if the animal test was so good would you
still feel comfortable going back to the
fish today the fish not so much because
they were so unreliable if the Frog
tests are still around and it was the
only option I had then sure but at the
end of the day it was so much easier
just to be able to walk into a chemist
pick up a test like this take it home
and then I was the first person to find
out that I was pregnant
[Music]